[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen zurück 10
Minuten Nachrichten die deutschen
Fußballfrauen kämpfen ja um den EM-Titel
Rudi aber es gibt noch mehr Sport heute
ja unter anderem DFB-Pokal erste Runde
mehr dazu später jetzt erstmal unsere
großen Themen im Überblick
neue Waffen für die russische Marine
Präsident Putin kündigt Aufrüstung an
kein Wiedereinstieg in die Atomkraft
grünen Chefin Ricarda lang spricht im
zdf-sommerinterview von
hochrisikotechnologie
und Medaillenflut im weitwasser zweimal
deutsches Gold zum Abschluss der
Kanuslalom WM in Augsburg
[Musik]
Präsident Putin hat die USA und die NATO
als größte Bedrohungen für Russland
bezeichnet erstellte heute eine neue
militär-doktrin für die Marine vor die
Behauptung darin die USA wollten die
Weltmeere beherrschen russland will
daher unter anderem seine
Schwarzmeerflotte Stärken über die
marineparade in St Petersburg und das
Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine
der 158 Tag des Krieges ist aus der
Sicht Moskau ein Tag der
hochglanz-bilder Paraden in mehreren
Städten am Tag der Marine Präsident
Putin in St Petersburg er kündigt die
Aufrüstung der Flotte mit
hyperschallraketen an und noch wichtiger
ersetzt eine neue Marine Doktrinen Kraft
in der er davor warnt Russland
Seegrenzen zu verletzen eine Botschaft
vor allem an die USA und ihre NATO
Verbündeten wir werden den Schutz
unserer Grenzen fest und mit allen
Mitteln sicherstellen der Schlüssel hier
sind auch die Fähigkeiten der Marine sie
ist in der Lage schnell auf jeden zu
reagieren der sich entscheidet in unsere
Souveränität und Freiheit einzugreifen
der Donbass am 158 Kriegstag der
russische Vormarsch geht weiter dass
jedenfalls sollen diese Bilder des
Verteidigungsministeriums zeigen die
Bedrohung der Zivilbevölkerung nimmt zu
dass sie doch die Regierung in Kiew
Präsident silenski appelliert an die
Bewohner im don-bust die Heimat zu
verlassen es gibt Hunderttausende von
Menschen Zehntausende von Kindern die
sich weigern zu gehen aber es muss
wirklich getan werden und je früher dies
geschieht desto weniger Menschen werden
von der russischen Armee in der Region
dort jetzt getötet werden
einen Drohnenangriff gab es heute auf
den Sitz der russischen
Schwarzmeerflotte in Sevastopol nur
wenige Stunden vor Putins Rede
offizielle Vertreter beschuldigen die
Ukraine deren Marine dementiert den
Angriff die Parade hier für jedenfalls
aus
angesichts des ukrainekrieges ringt
Deutschland darum wie wir unabhängig
werden von russischem Gas eine immer
lauter werdende Forderung Atomkraftwerke
länger am Netz zu lassen die Grünen aus
der anti-ackerw-bewegung hervorgegangen
würden zwar unter Umständen einen
zeitweisen Weiterbetrieb mittragen mehr
aber nicht und so gibt Streit mit dem
Koalitionspartner FDP heute war auch
dazu die ko-chefin der grün-recorder
lang im zdf-sommerinterview Thomas
Reichert bei diesem sommerinterview mit
der grünen Parteichefin sitzt noch ein
unsichtbarer Gast mit am Tisch Christian
Lindner hat noch mal erklärt notfalls
müssten Atomkraftwerke bis 2024 am Netz
bleiben der Konflikt in der Ampel hat
die offene Bühne erreicht wann geben sie
eigentlich die Gegenwehr für eine
Verlängerung auf das was Christian
Wiedner will ist nichts anderes als der
Wiedereinstieg in die Atomkraft und das
wird es mit uns auf jeden Fall nicht
geben lang wird Lindner eine unernte
Debatte vor atomkrafthilfe kaum
fehlendes russisches Gas zu er und es
ist so dass die Gaskraftwerke in
Deutschland nur zu einem sehr kleinen
Teil der Verstromung eingesetzt werden
und da nur zu einem winzigen Teil durch
die Atomkraft ersetzt werden könnte wir
haben ein Wärmeproblem kein Stromproblem
einzige Einschränkung bei ihrem AKW nein
wenn er neuer Stresstest auf
Schwierigkeiten beim Strom zeige lang
fordert wegen hohe Energiekosten
Geringverdiener weiter zu entlasten
finanziert zum Beispiel durch eine
übergewinnsteuer für Energiekonzerne die
aktuell für höhere Profite einfahren
wieder Widerspruch von Lindner der heute
ebenfalls vor die Kameras tritt wir
müssen alles tun um die Menschen zu
schützen vor der Inflation und ihre
Ursachen zu bekämpfen und in diesem Ziel
sind wir uns einig bei den Wegen gibt es
vielleicht auch unterschiedliche Reflexe
lang wiederum appelliert ein Lindners
Reflexe er solle seinen Widerstand
aufgeben mitten in der Krise die
Schuldenbremse noch länger auszusetzen
ich glaube da müssen dann alle bereit
sein mal über ihren Schatten zu springen
das erwarte ich auch vom
Koalitionspartner den Twist werden sich
spätestens am Ende des Sommers zu klären
haben wenn sie in der Regierung dann
tatsächlich alle wieder an einem Tisch
sitzen
und das gesamte sommerinterview mit der
grünen kur-chefin können Sie direkt im
Anschluss an diese Sendung sehen oder
jederzeit in unserer Mediathek
gerade erst hat das Bodenpersonal die
Lufthansa mit einem Streik lahm gelegt
jetzt rüsten sich auch deren Piloten und
Pilotinnen für einen Arbeitskampf in
einer Urabstimmung der Gewerkschaft
Cockpit sprach sich eine große Mehrheit
für einen Streik aus sollte die
Lufthansa kein besseres Angebot machen
sie fordern unter anderem 5,5% mehr
Gehalt und ein Inflationsausgleich
die Taten hatten für Entsetzen gesorgt
vor kurzem waren mehrere gedenkbäume für
Opfer des
ns-konzentrationslagers Buchenwald
zerstört worden
thüringsministerpräsident ramelo
kündigte daraufhin an sein Urlaub zu
unterbrechen und heute an einer
Gedenkveranstaltung für jüdische Kinder
teilzunehmen die von Buchenwald nach
Auschwitz deportiert wurden für sie
wurden weitere Steine verlegt ein
Bericht von Florian kocik
Musiker begleiten den Gedenkmarsch auf
diesem Weg Deportierten die Nazis 12.000
Kinder von Buchenwald ins
Vernichtungslager Auschwitz an sie
erinnern seit heute 111 weitere
Gedenksteine die Ermordeten sind
Menschen gewesen und ein ganzes Leben
ist zerstört worden und dieses Leben mit
dem Namen wieder zu Ehren und das hier
auf der alten Strecke zu platzieren das
ist so wichtig ganz in der Nähe des
ehemaligen Konzentrationslagers haben
Unbekannte in den vergangenen Wochen
wiederholt gedenkbäume gefällt und
zerstört auch waren getöteten Kindern
von Buchenwald sowie weiteren Häftlingen
gewidmet bundesweit hat das für
Entrüstung gesorgt wenn jemand Bäume
absägt die den Kindern und Jugendlichen
von Buchenwald gewidmet sind dann ist
das ein gezielter Angriff auf das
Gedenken auf die Erinnerungskultur das
ist politisch motiviert auch in der
Gedenkstätte kommt es immer wieder zur
rechtsextremen Schmierereien und
Hassbotschaften und nicht nur dort
wir sehen dass die Häufigkeit derartiger
Vorfälle in den letzten Jahren und im
Zuge der corona-pandemie zugenommen hat
der Vorfall gehört zu einer Form des
Antisemitismus der die
nationalsozialistischen Massenverbrechen
relativiert und bagatellisiert gerade
deshalb sei es umso wichtiger
Antisemitismus in all seinen Spielarten
zu bekämpfen mit Aufklärung Bildung und
Aktionen für das Erinnern und gegen das
Vergessen
[Musik]
china hat eine große transportrakete
nach dem Einsatz über Südostasien
abstürzen lassen was unter anderem die
NASA scharf kritisiert das Manöver sei
unkontrolliert gewesen um Peking habe
keine Informationen zu dem Vorgang
geteilt die meisten Teile der Rakete
verglühten bei dem Wiedereintritt in die
Erdatmosphäre aber offenbar stürzen auch
einige Trümmer vor den Philippinen ins
Meer für ein ähnlich riskantes Manöver
war China bereits vor gut einem Jahr
international kritisiert worden
ja und jetzt kommen wir wie versprochen
mit Rudi zum DFB-Pokal genau die ganz
große Überraschung blieb zwar aus aber
nur mit Mühe hatte SC Freiburg die
zweite Runde im dfb-vereins-pokal
erreicht beim Zweitliga Aufsteiger 1 fC
Kaiserslautern gelang der 2:1 Sieg erst
in der Verlängerung vor knapp 40.000
Zuschauern am Betzenberg musste der
Europa League Teilnehmer Freiburg eine
harte pokalprüfung bestehen in der 111
minute dann die Erlösung für den
Bundesligisten durch den Treffer von Liz
Dorn
so und hier sind die anderen Ergebnisse
der Pokalspiele von heute Kaiserslautern
also verliert wie gesehen gegen SC
Freiburg nach Verlängerung eins zu zwei
Sandhausen gewinnt in Reden 4:0 FC
Schalke 04 souverän weiter 15 0 Sieg
beim Bremer SV aus der vierten Liga
FV Engers verliert 1:7 gegen Arminia
Bielefeld auch Borussia Mönchengladbach
deutlich 9:1 in Oberachern SV
Rödinghausen unterliegt Hoffenheim erst
nach Verlängerung 0:2 shot Mainz
Hannover 96 023 der entstand Blau-Weiß
Lohne muss ich mit 0:4 gegen den FC
Augsburg geschlagen geben
und bei den Weltmeisterschaften in
Augsburg regnet es für die deutschen
Slalom Kanutinnen und Kanuten auch am
Abschlusstag Goldmedaillen in Augsburg
geboren im Augsburger Eiskanal zum
ersten Mal WM-Gold gewonnen für sideris
tasiatis schließt sich der Kreis der
Olympia dritte von Tokio riskiert im
Finale der Bootsklasse einer Kanadier
viel und wird belohnt im Ziel ist der
32-Jährige 1,18 Sekunden schneller als
Alexander slavkowski aus der Slowakei
Franz Anton sichert sich Bronze im einer
kanadier-finale der Frauen lässt Andrea
Herzog die Australierin und top
Favoritin Jessica Fox rund eine Sekunde
hinter sich und das trotz einer Stangen
Berührung nach 2019 das zweite WM-Gold
in Herzogs Karriere
Zeit für Olympiasiegerin animek van
fleuten hat die Tour de France der
Frauen gewonnen nachdem die 39 Jahre
alte Niederländerin gestern auf der
Königsetappe das Gelbe Trikot übernommen
hatte gewann sie heute auch das letzte
123,3 km lange Teilstück ihre Landsfrau
Demi vollein wurde sowohl auf der Etappe
als auch im Gesamtklassement zweite
Liane Lippert beendete als beste
deutsche die Tour auf Platz 14
Formel 1 Weltmeister Max Verstappen ist
in der Formel 1 auf dem besten Weg zur
Titelverteidigung in Ungarn stürmte er
von Startplatz 10 zum Sieg dem achten in
dieser Saison auf Platz 2 Lewis Hamilton
vor seinem Mercedes Teamkollegen George
Russell Sebastian Vettel wurde 10 Mick
Schumacher 14
jetzt haben wir alles durch das war's
Dankeschön Rudi und noch ein Blick aufs
Wetter im Osten und der Mitte viele
Wolken mit Schauern und Gewittern sonst
mehr Sonne am Nachmittag am Süden
einzelne Gewitter Höchstwerte 18 bis 31
Grad und in den nächsten Tagen wieder
zunehmen sonnig und hoch sommerlich heiß
mitreserin begrüßt sie um 21.45 zum
heute-journal und jetzt geht es hier
direkt weiter mit dem sommerinterview
mit der grünen ko-chefin lang schönen
Abend noch